je voulais pour débuter vous montrez 3
diapositives trois images ces images
représentent la façon dont des pays
s'adresse au monde la grande bretagne
dit qu'elle égrène la nouvelle zélande
dit qu'elle est pure l'inde dit qu'elle
est incroyable si le devions nous
adresser un message au monde
quel serait-il autour de quel consensus
pourrons-nous trouver quelque chose à
dire au monde alors je pense que si on
se posait la question par exemple de se
demander ce que les américains
pourraient dire au monde on irait très
facilement définir quelque chose autour
de l'american dream ça ce type de
questionnement c'est ce que les
américains appellent le nation building
que nous nous pouvons appeler la marque
nation
à quoi ça sert la france a des offres
des offres culturelles des offres
industrielles des offres agricoles des
offres gastronomique des offres
sportives des offres d'éducation de par
la mondialisation bien évidemment ces
offres sont en compétition avec d'autres
offres qui viennent d'autres endroits du
monde
le pari de la marque nation c'est de se
dire que ces pays et ces offres donc
pourrait se voir doter d'un a priori
positif que parce qu'elles seraient
françaises elle serait vue comme
singulière comme indispensable comme
irrésistible je crois qu'il est très
important ici de dire qu'il s'agit pas
de rouvrir le débat de l'identité
nationale
l'identité nationale c'est définir ce
qu'est nous structure la façon dont nous
voyons la marque nation c'est définir la
façon de nous souhaiterions que les
autres nous voient alors comment s'y
prend on pour révéler une marque qui
tout de même a été créé au cinquième
siècle
si cette marque existe c'est qu'elle a
des piliers assez fort qui est la
structure
alors ce qu'il faut c'est essayer de les
révéler alors les candidats sont légions
par exemple via le non conformisme et le
panache c'est pas très économique
je suis pas certain que ça ne fasse pas
de nous des gens un peu difficile c'est
un peu anecdotique alors à l'autre bout
du spectre au contraire l'imagination et
les idées d'ailleurs les responsables
internationaux les décideurs nous
crédite de cela mais revendiquées tels
que ça ferait colis de nous des gens un
peu compliqué qui serait un peu
prétentieux
alors il ya deux merveilleuses valeur
économique l'innovation
le problème c'est que les pays émergents
et les pays asiatiques en ont fait leur
cheval de bataille et ya la qualité la
qualité élément clé est fondamental dans
la mondialisation
mais là encore le problème c'est qu'on
par un peu tard et donc sur ce terrain
de la marque nations l'allemagne et la
suisse en ont fait leur apanage
dommage alors il nous reste le luxe et
l'art de vivre
mais là encore en matière économique en
termes de largeur de spectre c'est pas
comme on rentre la machine-outil là
dedans c'est pas comme on rentre les
services c'est pas comme on rentre le
digital puis si j'osais je vous poserai
la question c'est quoi une usine art de
vivre
alors je vous comme je propose quand
même trois piliers le premier de ses
piliers
l'amour des gestes des démarches des
savoir faire la france a élevé ses
savoir faire au niveau d'un art et avec
le japon la france est le seul pays à
avoir construit une culture autour de
ses savoir faire
ça commence comment ça commence par bien
sûr les gestes les démarches et le fait
de les nommer on les normes pas par
fétichisme mais c'est parce que c'est le
début de la création de valeur prenez un
geste vous le normes et une fois qu'ils
les normes et vous pouvez le transmettre
quand vous l'avez transmet vous pouvez
le dupliquer et donc vous créer les
conditions de la reproductibilité et
sacrés quatre choses comme ça l'
expertise
le fait de pouvoir nommer des maîtres la
capacité de juger
la capacité d'enseigner et je pense
qu'on se rend compte là pourquoi la
france fait des choses merveilleuses
dans la durée alors que d'autres bien
qu'étant qatar et créatifs sont dans la
fulgurance chacun de nos métiers a des
gestes et des démarches le luxe à ne
point sellier les logiciels en
schématique la distribution à ces
filières qualité vous devez tous vous y
retrouver 2e pilier la vision la france
veut mettre du sens dans tout ce qu'elle
fait la france ne fait jamais des
produits ou des services
quand la france veulent tgv elle
désenclave les villes
quand la france fait des produits
laitiers elle fait de l'alimentation
notre première médecine troisième pilier
l'art de la surprise la france n'est
jamais là où on l'attend elle ne veut
être une copie de rien elle ne veut
mettre ses pas dans les traces d'eau
qu'un autre est en tout elle va faire
modèle alors ça nous a amené à innover
et inventer
plus que n'importe qui au monde alors
quand je parle d'innovation
je ne parle pas du championnat du monde
du dépôt de brevet je parle des
innovations qui nous aide à mieux vivre
les allumettes c'est nous la serrure
c'est nous bon alors on va dire un peu
plus proche de notre vie d'aujourd'hui
les verres progressifs c'est encore nous
la bsc nous les formats de compression
divx c'est nous
le monde vit au rythme de nos
innovations plus que n'importe quel
autre pays au monde et ça nous amène des
fois être à des endroits totalement
inattendue si vous prenez la musique le
premier segment économique de la musique
c'est tout ce qui tourne autour de la
house la techno la dance
sur les 10 premiers mondiaux
huit sont français vous les connaissez
un ghetto de justice daft punk etc
c'est contre intuitif nous pouvons
penser que les anglo saxons joue à
domicile en la matière mais la réalité
est tout autre
parce que nous surprenons alors la mort
des gestes la vision
l'art de la surprise ceci peut nous
amener à définir une promesse savez en
marketing c'est cette chose qui définit
l'utilité des marques
la france n'est pas créateur de valeur
la france est un multiplicateur de
valeur la france multiplie la valeur de
toutes les choses qu'elle touche avec la
france les choses sont plus plus
ingénieuses plus visionnaires plus
étonnantes plus productive plus
sensibles la france est une sorte
d'exposants mathématiques les choses
sont factorielle france elles sont
puissance france et on voit qu ainsi
révélé le récit économique français n'a
rien à envier aux immenses récits
mythiques du monde donc ce qui nous
reste à faire c'est elle diffuse et là
c'est un peu compliqué dans un pays qui
n'est ni pro économique ni anti
économique un pays qui est à économie au
sens où il a gommé de son roman national
de toute référence à l'économie et ce
serait déjà une petite nouvelle
révolution française que de réussir à
réintégrer toute notre histoire
économique dans la grande histoire
française et dans ce terme marc nation
sait très bien qu'on n'est pas loin de 2
oxymore mais la france plus que tout
pays au monde devrait respecter ce terme
et ne devrait pas en avoir peur parce
que si nous sommes multiplicateur de
valeur pour être multiplicateur de
valeur savoir lire
savoir écrire faveur du temps faut être
en bonne santé
faut faire les choses avec éthique faut
faire les choses avec responsabilité et
ça c'est le modèle social français
si nous sommes multiplicateur de valeur
c'est parce que nous sommes
historiquement et socialement ce que
nous sommes et ainsi la france peut
revendiquer comme toutes les grandes
nations qui domine le concert
international
le fait de marcher sur deux jambes d'un
côté notre modèle historique et sociale
liberté égalité fraternité
invité de l'autre côté notre modèle
économique
la multiplication de valeur pouvoir
définir la marque france est une chance
exaltante
c'est la nôtre parce que la marque
nation nous en sommes les acteurs nous
sommes les contributeurs nous en sommes
les relais donc il ne faut laisser à
personne d'autre que nous et surtout pas
aux préjugés qui sont larmes des
fainéants le fait de s'occuper de cette
marque il faut la prendre à bras le
corps et il faut tous y apporter notre
définition
merci beaucoup